let's talk about the new race for space
countries and companies are competing to
develop brand new space technology right
now engineers are designing space
colonies it's time to go back to the
moon this time to stay France and the US
have even launched their own space force
a space force as the sixth branch of the
Armed Forces that's a big statement
so in this race who could win and what's
the big prize and why should you and I
care about what's happening up there
[Music]
let's take a second to realize how close
the future actually is space tourism is
taking off billionaire Richard Branson
just made his commercial space airline
Virgin Galactic the first publicly
traded company of its kind her little
company's gonna be floating in space
next year and today it's floating on the
stock market and earlier this year he
opened a spaceport in New Mexico where
customers who've paid two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars each will soon
board space planes to Earth's sup orbit
you've probably also heard of the
billionaire Elon Musk
and his company SpaceX he's unveiled
detailed plans to start construction on
Mars in just 30 years time we want to
just keep improving rocket technology
until there's a city on Mars now I know
it all sounds incredibly ambitious but
big ideas can become very real very
quickly it's happened before during the
first space race in the 1950s the US and
Soviet Union were locked in a cold war
over political ideology President Truman
signs a bill to spend over three billion
dollars to fight communism both sides
started developing bigger and better
rocket technology to use in a potential
nuclear war and to keep each other in
check but they quickly took that fight
to space space travel became headline
news with the announcement that the
United States plan to launch their first
satellite by 1957
but the Soviets beat them to it by
launching Sputnik a tiny satellite that
Washington feared could zip over the US
and gather intelligence four years later
the Soviet Union made history again by
putting the first human in space but
soon enough US President John F Kennedy
raised the stakes in 1969 NASA put the
first humans on the moon as to who won
that I think it's pretty clear that the
USA won that race but it wasn't just
about national prestige in the simple
flag-waving sense that's why there was
such an emphasis on the various
scientific instruments that were flown
with the Apollo missions what followed
that first space race were in fact many
decades of science driven space
exploration countries even collaborated
with each other's space programs to send
Space Station's telescopes probes and
satellites across our solar system NASA
stayed in the lead partly because of its
space shuttle but over time governments
around the world started pouring less
money into their space programs
including the u.s. eventually NASA
retired the shuttle for good in 2011 and
in the meantime new space powers emerged
countries like China and India who have
been pouring millions of dollars into
their space programs China and India are
basically trying to one-up each other in
terms of getting into records folks with
China going to the far side of the Moon
in India trying to Land Rovers other
planets
and we show a country's technological
prowess which turns into geostrategic
employees but it's private companies and
the pockets of billionaires who've
really been heating up the race SpaceX
has built the world's first reusable
rocket and the company has been working
with NASA to transport cargo to the
International Space Station the airplane
manufacturer Boeing and a company called
Blue Origin owned by Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos are also competing for contracts
so are dozens of other startups around
the world including rocket lab in New
Zealand and eye space in Japan and the
idea is that if companies can profit
science does - the big prize is
obviously for any private entity is - is
to be profitable and makeup and make a
business space is very hard it is very
expensive for us for example it's doing
really important things that really
benefit humanity in some ways and make a
profit and the rewards could potentially
be enormous NASA believes there are
nearly 800,000 asteroids in our solar
system which contain valuable metals
like gold iron and platinum and just
many of those asteroids called 16 psyche
is thought to have about 700 quintillion
US dollars worth of valuable materials
there are also very real plans to mind
the moon for water and helium-3 which
could both potentially be transformed
into rocket fuel allows us to resupply
our missions to Mars and we can even
refuel orbiting satellites of Earth and
guess what laws have already been
drafted in the US and Luxembourg to
allow companies to keep what they mine
on the moon Mars or anywhere else the
companies aren't going to invest their
money if they think that whatever they
are able to mine belongs to mankind they
want it to belong to them and the United
States passed legislation which
basically said okay we're good with that
and there was some international
criticism of the why does it belong to
and that leads us to another prize in
this race which is power even after the
Cold War space exploration has in some
ways been driven by the military no
government officials military officials
are saying that they would like to have
weapons developed and deployed by 2023
there was a loose year
the rupee or the capacity Don will
demand de la serda physics space comm
will defend America's vital interests in
space the next war fighting domain but
there are no actual weapons in space yet
there is an internationally agreed outer
space treaty to stop weapons of mass
destruction from being used in space we
have very few guidelines there are no
weapons of mass destruction to be placed
in outer space
we are not to militarize the moon but
other than that it's open territory
already the US Russia China and India
have carried out what they call
anti-satellite missiles by destroying
old satellites in space for no other
countries and companies say they are
putting science first and that's a good
thing because it'll push the boundaries
of human technology and could bring us
the answers to life's big questions and
unlike the last space race this time
there seems to be more room for everyone
hopefully that means everybody wins
hi thank you so much for getting in
touch and sending us all your ideas for
stories you want us to tackle next keep
those coming and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to our Facebook page and to
this YouTube channel and that way you'll
get a notification when we post our next
episode